a heat wave has occurred because the
heat has been pumping its way out of the
northwest of Africa across Spain and
Portugal where we have seen a
record-breaking temperatures curler
Cloud just offshore from the Iberian
Peninsula has been drawing winds in from
a southerly Direction that's going to
continue making its way further
northwards as the Azores high this area
of high pressure here just uses a little
further eastwards it opens the
floodgates for that heat to Surge up
across France pushing up towards the UK
by the time we come to Monday
temperatures here getting up to around
35 Celsius in London or more touch
warmer still as we go on into Tuesday
and somewhere across the UK particularly
into the south and east I suspect we'll
see temperatures getting close to if not
touching 40 degrees celsius thankfully
by Wednesday something a little fresher
just topples in from Western past as
that heat just surges into Central parts
of Europe so is it down to climate
change that's the big question well as
you can see from these NASA charts
climate scientists have been telling us
for decades now that we are allowed to
see an increase in the severity and the
frequency of heat waves because of
global warming and we take a closer look
at the UK here's some of that evidence
here as well since 1900 to 2002
temperatures have reached 35 degrees
Celsius on 9k Asians since 2003 we've
seen that occur on seven occasions seven
out of the ten hottest years here have
occurred since 2003.